Dự án mở giống có lộn mẹ ba năm trong góm công chính nân cấp đường hiện hiệu ở thành phố, thực hiện theo hình thức B-O-T,
sây dựng kinh rang trên dau, đoạn có lộn được nân cấp dài khoảng 6 kí lâu mét,
từ câu bình chiệu đến vinh mình, báo gồm cả phần đường đầu cầu thực tình mình dương cố.
Dự án có quy mô mở giống mặt đường từ bốn đến sấu lần xe, lên mùi lần, giống sống mùi mét,
cùng hàng lăng trong kây sang công chính hạt tân ký thuật sọc bên.
Nói mở giống mặt đường khoảng 8,5 kí lâu mét ở dưới tướng sẽ sây dựng đi trên cao, câu cặt,
với quy mô mũi lần xe, hai bên là đường xong hành.
Tổn mức đầu thực sự án gần hai mối ngình tỷ đồng trong đó nân xe thành phố tham gia hơn mởi bốn nghiên sấu chăm tỷ đồng cho giảm thành phần một,
môi thường phố trở, đại điện cư, phân con lại khoảng 6,5% mối tỷ đồng,
gió nhà đầu thực tự thủ sét, chình hai sự án thành phần hai, nân cấp mở giọc.
Sau khi hoàn thành, nhà đầu tư dựng kiến thu phí hoàn bốn trong 184 tháng,
theo kế hoạch được sở sê dựng đưa ra, công trình sẽ khởi công và quy bốn năm 2018,
hoàn thành sau đó hai năm.